Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Connors, welcome to another episode of Connors Clinic Live.
We have a special guest, person that I just met a few months ago, but it's been
become a quick friend because I love what she does. Janet Danielson is from Canada,
lives in Mexico. She is the leader, the inventor of equipment for health. She is a leader of
Meda District, which is a studio, a bloody studio, health studio, exercise studio,
health recovery studio, really, and a bunch of online courses that we're really recommending a lot
of our members to start to get involved with. And this really simple ball that she invented,
called the Coach Ball, that seems so simple, but she's going to spend some time today explaining it
to us. And I'm going to turn the microphone over to you, young lady. Dr. Connors, thank you so
much for that introduction. I'm so I'm happy to be here. I want to just start by, I want to show you
the ball. You know, when Dr. Connors said it's simple, it's simple, it truly is a ball. I'm going to talk
a little bit about how this came to be, how it has helped the tens of thousands of people that I have
come in contact with, and why the body is amazing at healing when you can understand it,
communicate with it, and give it what it needs. So I am a bloody instructor,
turned pelvic floor champion because of my own pain early on in my life. I'm the mom of three
boys, and I watch TV. And so all those things, you see these commercials about
incontinence products and the commercials which show these big, burly construction workers,
and the fancy lady in her business suit, with this newly designed incontinence product
now at your local grocery store or pharmacy that you could pick up. And I wanted to do a little bit
of research. And so did you know that the incontinence product industry was a 14 billion dollar
industry? Why are so many people all over the world subscribing to this product as the solution
for an issue in the body that's really about muscles, right? So if you wanted to get stronger arms
or stronger legs, or have better posture, you would work on the muscles to change that.
And yet when it comes to pelvic floor health, the first issue was no one was talking about it. And it
kind of made me a little bit mad because this is our body. And why are we not talking about it?
It wasn't until recently that I learned that we have what the main nerve that comes from the brain
into our pelvic floor is called the pudendle nerve. It is a sensory nerve which means it creates
sensations. And it's a motor nerve. So it takes the communication from the brain to that area
so that it can function properly. And I just want to add that the pelvic floor is designed to
it's designed for multi functions. It folds our pelvic organs up inside of us. We live on a
planet with gravity. It's the floor of our core. So if it's not properly functioning because we live
on a planet with gravity, over time those organs inside our body are bladder and women are uterus.
They're going to start to descend. So functionally we need this muscle to be responding so that it can
simply hold our organs inside of us. It's a very sensual muscle as well. So when it works good,
it works good. And in a monk status sprinkled all these moments of lack of confidence and pain.
Often there can be trauma to that area. And we become very disconnected. We can get a lot of pain in
our hips, a lot of tightness in our low back. And what some people don't realize is simple experiences
like cold tingly feet, like constipation. Those are just two very regular examples of actual
pelvic floor dysfunction. It doesn't mean that you're going to cough or sneeze and pee a little bit.
Pelvic floor can be so much more than that. I think most people know the term pelvic floor muscles
and they kind of get an idea what you're talking about, but they don't know how it correlates to
the greater picture of health. They might go to the point that they go, that's just for
incontinence. And I don't have incontinence, you know, I'm not by adult diapers yet. So that's not
an issue for me. But there's literally almost nobody that goes to the step you're talking about
that I can tie into constipation, you know, bowel habit, regularity. It could tie into low back pain.
It could tie into neuropathy issues. It could tie into lower extremity paid and depaid and
abdominal paid menstrual irregularity dysfunction with with male function, sexual function, female
sexual function. I mean, you just go on and on. Everything basically, you know, from the bottom of
the ribs down, any dysfunction can be tied to this, that muscle that is supposed to be, you know,
holding everything up. That's a key point, I think that listeners need to grasp that it's more than,
why don't we're diapers? So I don't need to think about this. So what a lot of people don't know is
that in about 90% of cases erectile dysfunction in men post prostate cancer, surgery in men,
and in incontinence pelvic floor pain in women, 90% of those people who are seeking medical attention
actually could heal and regain function through proper movement and proper understanding of how
the body works. If there were 10 women in a waiting room in a clinic waiting for a pelvic floor mesh
pinup surgery, only one of those 10 actually needs to go into that room and get that surgery done.
And that was researched done by Dr. Bruce Crawford, who's a Eurogenicologist out of Reno, Nevada.
So what do you do? That's the question. What do you do to have to do? Yeah.
Experts do I have to buy this big piece of equipment that's going to sit in the corner of my bedroom
and become a clothes hanger? What do I know? Not at all. Not at all. And you know, there are like
internal, and I'm a big proponent of pelvic floor physiotherapist. I think it's very important to
have an internal examination. But what I realized through all the kinesiology and personal training
research is that a muscle fiber, our facial connective tissue, our nerve tissue, it needs oxygen
rich, nutrient rich blood to be a flourishing tissue. So like a plant. If we don't water a plant,
if we don't have that plant in sunshine, the plant is not going to flourish. Our muscle fibers,
our connective tissue, our communication system through our nerves is not going to flourish.
When we have corposter, when we are dehydrated, when we don't have proper nutrition,
our sleep isn't on point. All of those things point to a lack of blood flow.
When there's a lack of blood flow, there's a lack of environment to change, which means simply
we have to create the environment for change. And that's exactly what the koochball does. It's also
co-branded for the guys as the koochball. So my husband and I use the same product, but here's really
how it works. When you sit on the ball and you can sit on the floor, you can sit on a chair. It doesn't,
you don't have to cross your legs in front of you. It's very accessible, depending, you know,
doesn't really discriminate between getting on the floor or not. When the weight of the body
sits on the ball and the ball is about two-thirds full for optimal experience in the body,
if you know a little bit about fascial work and you would take a foam roller and roll out your
legs, it's kind of like a hurt so good experience, that's what I'm trying to mimic in the pelvic floor.
When you're sitting on the ball for simply three minutes a day, going through proper diaphragmatic
breathing in through your nose and out through your mouth and understanding that when you inhale
your pelvic floor is at rest and when you exhale, it's like when you're sitting on the ball,
it's like you're lifting an elevator, the elevator is going up into the body and then on the
exhale, the elevator is returning to the lobby. When you understand that concept and know what that
feels like in the body, the weight of the body on the ball creates the fascia release, so now we're getting
oxygen-rich, nutrient-rich blood to the area. So now these tissues are like having a party because
they can actually, they're like, yes, please, I would love all this nutrition and then through the
breath work that I teach simultaneously, you're teaching the new function, the improved function.
So whether you have a pelvic floor that's too tight, we call it hypertonic, like a rock wall,
or whether your pelvic floor is hypotonic, a lack of tone, it's kind of like the perfect storm because
the weight of the body on the ball does the release, the breathing on the ball does the activation or
the function. So you're getting both sides of the coin and your body is kind of drinking up exactly
how much of each of those experiences release and strength it needs in that moment. How did you
come up with it? Well, you know, you started teaching Pilates, is that right? You know, I just, again,
I taught fitness for many years before I taught Pilates and I always believed that my core was my
six-pack, those were my abs. It wasn't until I started doing my Pilates training that I realized that
the core is a three-dimensional cylinder. It has a roof, which is your diaphragm, it has a floor,
which is the pelvic floor, and then it has four different muscles that create the abdominal cylinder.
Through my Pilates training, this all came together and I was like, wait, what? You mean the six-pack
abdominals, we shouldn't be chasing those and in fact, we shouldn't be. It's the deepest set of abdominals
called the transverse abdominis, which are the main muscle of respiration. That's what the diaphragm
talks to and nobody seemed to have known this and I was like, why aren't we talking about this? Why
aren't we teaching this? And so that's, you know, I just, when I realized there was a lack of understanding
and a lack of tool to help men and women outside of the medical system understand this,
I decided to actually, it was my husband one, I reading supper and I was kind of, you know,
a little bit of an edgy mood and I was like, ah, we need to, you know, I need to spread the news
and he said, well, create a solution then. And I created the coach ball and it really haven't
looked back. It's, you know, if the ball is easy to use, it comes with training videos for men and
women because I believe that the education around this is absolutely key. And once you understand
that, you'll notice, you'll do what I call, live what you learn. I don't want you just focusing on your
pelvic floor when you're sitting on your coach or coach ball. I want you to understand that when you're
picking up, you know, big boxes when you're doing your fall cleaning or, you know, when you are doing
your yard work or when you're out for a walk or when you're on vacation in Europe walking on those
cobblestone streets and you need to create more stability in your body. I want the pelvic floor to
work for you. I don't want us to believe that because there's been another candle on our birthday cake
that we should wave the white flag and experience these, you know, these things that society has told us
all week chose to be a mom and have a baby. Well, welcome to the peak club. You get a lifetime membership
and that's not the case. It truly is a mindset shift. So I don't, you know, you don't want either
people value this or not using it. So what comes with it? You mentioned the videos. So is it on
your website? When you purchase it, you watch the training videos. Yeah. So what happens? You, you, the
coach ball bundle comes with the ball and it's deflated. So you get a pump that comes with it and you pump
it up two thirds. There's like a little intro postcard in there. So you can, it's called the quick start
guide. And then what you'll get access to is your very own student dashboard where when you buy
the coach ball bundle, you actually get both the create your pelvic floor upgrade course, which is
focused on women and their body. Then you also get the Gucci power course and my husband Jason actually
is in that one. And we talk all about the pelvic floor from a male perspective as well. There is a
bonus pelvic floor secrets webinar in there because it really is the layered learning that starts to help
you live what you learn. So basically the bundle, you have the whole A to Z or soup to nuts packaged
for you to start improving your quality of life. Now, you know, Dr. Conner's, I do want to say I've
mentioned three minutes a few times for many, many people when they sit on the ball, there's going to be
what we call the ouch factor. And the ouch factor is the biofeedback that the body is giving you. So when
you sit on the ball, you might only sit for 15 seconds for the first week. And then maybe you'll go
up to 30 seconds. But here's the key. As long as your breath is your guide that you're breathing in and out
very calmly, you're not triggering your sympathetic nervous system, which is that fight or flight.
As soon as you get on the ball and that ouch factor is a little bit higher than you would like, we will
naturally protect. We might not breathe as calmly, you're communicating to your sympathetic nervous
system alarm bells. And everything is going to protect instead of allowing the release to happen.
So that's my one role is allow your breath to be your guide. If you find yourself holding your breath,
ripping through your jaw, sit on your couch, sit on your mattress. There's ways that you can take a
little bit, take a little bit of air out of it. There's ways to customize this. And it might take
you three months to work up to three minutes. But what I can tell you is when you get off the ball,
over time, you're going to feel this beautiful, warm, tingly sensation. That's blood flow. So you're
going to become very almost like a connoisseur of your health and wellness from the inside out.
And you're going to understand what's going on. And that's extremely empowering when we know
how to connect the dots between what we just did and how the body benefited.
So I mean, it's very exciting to say we're going to have an exercise that's going to help support
our whole abdominal cavity. And at maximum, it's going to take us three minutes a day. You might
only be able to do it for 20 seconds a day to begin with. It's a lot better than thinking that I have
to put in a 20-minute time-all exercise video in order to start feeling healthy. So it's doable.
When exercise and so important of an exercise is this, it just seems a little more overwhelming
to people than it's just that they don't do it. So what good is it? So this is simple, easy to do
and doable. Do you have any like age limits like a person is 85 years old and they're thinking
about their mother with dementia? What would be your recommendation for somebody like that?
You know, I really have. And that's the one thing I say about this. This little tool really doesn't
discriminate. I've had, I believe, from what I know, my oldest coachball client is 92, or was 92
when she bought this. We even people that have advanced stages of osteoporosis, right? When you're
sitting on the ball, there can be a little bit of instability. So what I say for my clients who are
in that realm where they might have some osteoporosis or some osteoarthritis and their confidence with
maybe sitting on a heart chair on a ball with the instability, simply sit on your couch or put a cushion
on your chair, add to the stability that way. I've had children actually as young as 10 and 11
years old, their moms buy them the couch ball because they are dealing with bed weighting and they won't
go for sleep overs to their friends house because they have a lack of confidence. And even in those young
kids, they are usually high caliber athletes or dancers and they're holding this tension in their
body because of their sport or their art. And by virtue of that, their pelvic floor gets tight and
they have these bed wedding episodes. So it really does span, it spans, it's really ageless. I'm
going to say keep it away from your four-legged furry friends because they like these puppies like
this hall too. It is not puppy friendly. It's very easy for them to get their teeth into this.
Someone said, you need to create the pooch ball to come with the pooch ball so I can have a ball
for my dog to play with. And then I can have my own ball. And of course, when someone is unsure,
I always recommend, if you have a movement expert in your realm of health and wellness professionals
or physiotherapists, always check with them because everyone's situation is very different.
I'm excited about it. We're going to have links down here for our listeners to get one of these.
So how long does it take to get one state order at a week or so? Yeah, yeah. And you know,
we fulfill out of the US. So if you're in the US, it doesn't take long at all. We do fulfill
internationally. So just be a little bit patient if you are in Australia or over in the UK.
It takes just a couple of days longer. And like Dana said, all the videos come with it.
Your quick start guide. You're up and running. You're using this. It's not taking you 40 minutes
a day to start getting healthy and see really some changes with constipation on all sorts of
neurological issues and abdominal issues that can come along with a lot of our listeners have
cancer and have had surgery. Huge thing to help build those pelvic floor muscles back.
Dana, thanks so much for being with us today. I appreciate it. And I wanted you to give a little
bit of plug about something else you got coming up here too. Yes. Yeah. Well, you are a guest on it.
So we are doing the Medicine of Mindset Summit in conjunction with Dr. Talks. And it is happening
from January 24th to 31st. That's actually how Dr. Conner's and I met. He was so gracious to be on
what is my very first hosting gig with the summit. Now this summit is truly, if you if you love
this little taste of our conversation here, there's more of it. There's actually a week, a week long
experience for you. We believe very strongly myself and those people that said yes to my invitation
to be on the summit, that oftentimes whether you've been living with chronic pain, whether your
medication is not doing it for you anymore, whether you just have this gut feeling that there is a
different way to live. This is what we've curated in this week from the 24th to the 31st of January.
You're going to hear from specialists about movement, about nutrition. You're going to hear from
specialists that are experts in, you know, cancer care in diabetes care. That is happening. We would
love for you to be there. We're going to put the link below as well. It is absolutely free for
you to attend. And I'm just such a believer that information is empowering and information might
challenge some of those belief systems that you're ready to like a snake kind of shed that skin
and look at the, you know, the beauty of our body and fall in love with it again. I think we very
easily fall out of love with our body because it doesn't function. It doesn't look. It doesn't feel
like we wanted to or it doesn't. We go through maybe an Instagram feed and we become really
disassociated from it because we see all of these other things. And yet we weren't born with
replacement parts. All of these pieces are meant to last us till our very last day. And one of my favorite
quotes from Joseph Pilates is, you know, breath is the first and the last act of life. And somewhere
in the middle, we forget how to do it. That translates into the whole mind body spirit theme of
this week. So we would love you to be there at the medicine of mindset summit. Yeah, that's going
to be nice. And if you're listening to this a year from now, we'll have replay information as well.
So thank you again. I appreciate all you do. We have very much in common.
Hannah Danielson and this is Dr. Cutters. Cutters could apply. We'll see you next time.